make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I try to record this before and
for some reason it didn't take so we're
gonna try it again which actually works
out because here's what we're gonna do
okay so for the boys this story is
pretty hardcore so here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna put the as safe as
we can make it version on YouTube right
so like I've worked cutting stuff out
different things like that I'm not
really revealing a lot of like the
extreme stuff and then like further for
the the fans who really want like the
uncut version we're gonna put that one
on on patreon right so it'll cost you
like a buck or something like that if
you want to see it but you'll see the
uncut versions whenever they come out
but the boys a lot of you guys been
asking for this and maybe I'm too late
here right like maybe nobody cares I'm
not really sure but the boys is a pretty
intense comic there's a pretty hardcore
comic insofar as the others there's
really no punches pulled here that's the
beauty of kind of having what's
basically an indie comic because you can
just sort of get away with your own
thing guys it's dynamite entertainment
so um it's cool with with what Grant
Morrison can do but what it does is it
initially picks up with Billy butcher
now Billy butcher being here is is one
of these things where like right off the
bat like Garth Ennis gives us this
perspective right because you got Billy
butcher sitting on a park bench in front
of the Capitol building and like some
superheroes fly over and he's like I'm
gonna I'm gonna get you guys like like
literally I'm gonna tear you guys up so
right off the bat we know that he
absolutely despises superheroes and then
at this point we switch over to Huey now
for Huey I feel a little bit bad but at
the same time it was also kind of funny
because I I saw this and I was like dude
that sucks and it's not funny all right
it's not funny so so in the TV show you
he's introduced to us as a guy who's
basically a loser right he just can't
get his life together right I mean you
just got you so little most parents in
despite the fact that he's he's a grown
man right should definitely have his own
place but he's still living with his dad
and and Robin for the most part here
their relationship is on the rocks and
while I wouldn't go as far as to say
that Robins giving him the boot in the
TV show he was certainly being handed
his hat right um he wasn't really out of
the game but he was on his way out the
door and she was getting ready to bring
in whoever it was that she was gonna
bring in max right and so this comic
okay Huey's basically on his way out in
the comic it's not that way
and the comic him and Robin are very
much in love and like it's one of these
things were they they started dating not
too long ago but she's like I knew after
a week that I was ready to marry you so
like there's no indication that things
are going south and in fact the two of
them are basically just now getting
engaged right is just one of these
things where it's like we're meant to be
together so like they're engaged they're
in it to win it they're off to the races
which in reality
I find this to be a lot more intriguing
than what we saw in the show right
because in the show it's got like okay
yeah she should probably leave him
because the guys kind of a loser he can
get his life together whatever but like
she can probably do better word to the
wise for all those young folks out there
if you're a guy be a guy worth dating
right they saved the 1950s anymore but
ladies be a woman worth having just
because you're a woman does not mean
you're a woman worth dating be someone
worth dating that's the the number one
rule when it comes to the dating game
all right like it's it's a very
important thing but it's kind of a cool
thing it's kind of sad because when
they're celebrating their engagement
they're celebrating their engagement
together and then WHAM
this guy goes flying into a brick wall
Robin goes with him her arms get ripped
off and Huey's just standing there with
this chick's arms in his hands it's it's
mess okay it's not funny or it's it's
it's not funny an age range is like get
out of the way just like just like goes
just like takes off right just like
takes off running now from here it
switches over to to the Central
Intelligence Agency to the CIA and this
is one of the craziest parts of the
story right so you've got this chick
right Susan rayner who's basically the
director of the CIA now her and billy
butcher go back a little ways right they
went back to Afghanistan when they
bombed a village and the idea well we'll
talk about more of a more of why she
views Billy the way she does but it's
kind of a crazy theme because it's like
less she's basically told by her by your
secretary he looked Billy butcher's on
his way in and she's like okay like hold
all my calls but the idea behind this is
that she is she's working with Billy
butcher because the two of them have a
history going back a ways but
technically Billy worked directly with
her predecessor right so that when she
came on she inherited all this
information about what Billy is about
now
Billy butcher basically had a team at
one point that was designed to
essentially monitor superheroes and then
act against them if they needed to you
right so it was kind of they were they
were almost kind of like this
clandestine blackops arm that allowed
the CIA to operate in the borders of the
United States which it's not supposed to
do but create a kind of absorbency right
so that if things went south
if Billy butcher and his team were found
out the CIA could cut ties and be like
we don't know who they are and absolve
itself of any wrongdoing right and just
kind of kind of let them go um it's a
it's a it's a kind of a cool little
connection there because it allows both
parties to benefit but what it shows is
the CIA actually has a vested interest
and trying to find a way to either bring
down superheroes or find out what
they're truly up to right because what
this environment is showing us is this
is not the DC Comics you know
where you got Superman who's always
doing the right thing and you have
Batman who's kind of a dick but still
doing the right thing and then you have
cyborg who's just sitting around the
watchtower watching like Avatar The Last
Airbender
somebody somebody explained this to me
what's the stance on the audience on
this on the fan base between Avatar The
Last Airbender and The Legend of Korra
right like somebody explained that to me
I need to know what the what the stance
is between these two groups because I've
seen a lot of infighting I've seen
people who are just like I like Legend
of Korra
and then like avatar fans like burn them
like I've heard all kinds of different
different things it's kind of crazy but
the long and short of this is that with
Billy butcher working with his team
because of fact they kind of predate the
current director of the CIA because they
predate Susan brainer she knows to work
with them because she knows they're
effective but she doesn't really want to
and as one of these things where she's
kinda like she's doing it but not
necessarily because she wants to more
because it's in their interest to do it
and because Billy butcher is the kind of
guy who can get things done right he can
who can basically make sure things get
taken care of now one of the things I'd
also want to point out to you is one of
the differences that really seems to
happen between the early part of this
comic and the TV show is in the TV show
a train ran into Robin and that's
basically what cost her her arms right
like he hit her at SuperSpeed
but what seems to have gone on here is
this not superheroes getting getting
normal people killed it really almost
kind of feels like the latter half or
the the second act of Kingdom Come right
where you basically have people with
superpowers who were act they're acting
recklessly and they don't really care
what kind of impact they have on the
general public right that's kind of how
that feels but one of the Heartless
nature's of the superheroes come into
play when Hugh is like losing his mind
over losing his fiancee and a train is
like you gotta people take care of this
right cool cuz I gotta go can't stop
they train baby and like takes off and
just goes running it's pretty heartless
like it's kind of a dick thing but
following this we also go into what
really kind of appears to be this darker
clandestine situation here when you have
Hughie who basically met by these men in
black and so what they end up doing here
is basically saying hey look we'd like
you to sign this agreement that
basically says that you won't say
anything then you'll be compensated
accordingly right so what it looks like
is there's a kind of entity out there
that has a vested interest in trying to
make sure that he put a superhero stay
in a positive light
that any incident that involves a
superhero potentially getting somebody
killed either by direct or indirect
action has to be hushed has to be kept
quiet so the general public kind of goes
on with a facade that heroes are there
to save them and they're there to do the
good do the good thing you know fight
the good fight that kind of stuff which
again shows that it's superheroes acting
in a very dark way but also shows that
you've got entities out
design that are invested and making sure
the superheroes are portrayed a certain
way right so from their us you switch
over to a guy named Kessler Kessler is a
guy who's basically a CIA analyst now
Kessler working as part of the CIA is
kind of like the the information man
right so for those of you guys who are
familiar with the Punisher think of like
microchip well he's like the microchip
to billy butcher basically in the sense
that he's the guy that basically
collects information on behalf of
superheroes for the CIA he does it
secretly no one knows that he does and
then he pad used to pass that
information off to Billy butcher and now
he's doing it again right like Billy
shows up and says we're getting the team
back together uh it's time to start
working together again and so it's kind
of a cool thing here because this is
when he basically learns about Huey
now to the to the average Joe out there
to the average person they see whatever
the spin was in the newspapers right
they see what the newspapers want them
to see partly because they're probably
only sticking to that source material
and to because they're probably too lazy
to look up anything else but they
basically see what the news wants them
to see but the reality is that Hughie's
caught up in a scenario where his fiance
was killed by the action of a superhero
and Billy butcher sees that Billy
butcher says okay so this guy is so in
that we can basically rally to our cause
and so where you have Huey sitting there
just like struggling and dealing with
the grief of losing his fiancee he
suddenly met by the arrival of Billy
butcher and this is the cool thing here
is because Billy butcher presents
himself as a guy who's kind of like a
very very much a savior right like hey
I'm here to help you out and I see
you've been through some rough things
and I want to make life easier on you
you know I want to make life better on
you I want to put you in a situation to
where you can basically you know be okay
and you can help get past this I know
you felt like you lost someone I can
basically help you get to a place where
you're gonna experience happiness uh
you're gonna move away from this dark
element this dark place that you've been
in he really kind of shows himself and
persists himself as a savior of source
you know I can solve all your problems
and so at that point it jumps over to
Frenchmen now a Frenchman in the comic
at least in this introduction I think is
actually more interesting than the TV
show he's cool in the TV show but in the
comic he's almost kind of poetic I mean
he is in the show too but in the comic
he's kind of poetic and so far he's kind
of going on about himself and kind of
minding his own business and so on and
some guys basically call him like like
sarcone they call him like a fridge and
it's like okay so like whatever man like
like if that's the kind of game you want
to play and it's cool because with these
guys giving him a hard time
he basically helps them to understand
their place in the bigger picture right
and say hey look you know you guys are
coming to this from the perspective that
I'm just like some average guy out there
ah let me help you understand that I'm a
person you don't mess with and so these
guys basically learn to understand the
third place
bigger picture is on the floor bleeding
and suffering it's cool to see bullies
get dealt with in that way right and so
as it's a it's it's it's a cool little
moment because then when Billy butcher
shows up Frenchmen greets him as a
friend and so this is again Garth Ennis
basically telling us at some point along
the line billy butcher and frenchman
worked together as a single unit work
together as a team and that's kind of
where we are now right the two of them
kind of functioning together and so from
there you go into the girl now in the TV
show the girl was introduced in a much
different way right I mean those guys
who saw the show the girl was introduced
as somebody who was just like you know
stuck in a cage basically you know she
was held in a cage down in like some
really seedy you know place look like a
meth lab to be honest and initially the
way it was depicted it looked like she
was a person being held for the purpose
of just like whatever needs and desires
the people who were holding her we're
using her for it of course we end up
learning later on there was a much
bigger plot going on there but in this
instance she just shows up at somebody's
house now we're not really given a
backstory here we just have her knocking
on a door of what seems like a pretty
seedy spot like you know a very violent
spot with some very bad guys and when
they opened the door she massacres them
all rips one of their faces off
literally just kills everybody in there
and so it's kind of nuts because of
course Billy butchers going to recruit
her and that's one of the common themes
and I hope you guys are picking up Billy
butcher is travelling around and
recruiting people that have a vendetta
against superheros and if you're gonna
be a person who operates against
superheroes that's really what you need
right otherwise you end up running into
somebody who gets turned into a double
agent
and then suddenly your operations dead
before it even started and so again it's
it's it's cool in terms of how all this
is sort of coming together but it's an
interesting thing because the question
it was asked by Huey is why do you want
me in your ranks and indeed us as the
reader were asked in that question why
in the world does Billy butcher want
Huey like what does Huey have to offer
he's just a guy and the responsibilities
butcher is I want someone who's felt it
before I want someone who knows what
it's like to lose someone to a superhero
and what this indicates is that Billy
butcher himself has lost someone to a
superhero for those you guys watching
the show a lot of you guys are really
familiar with that but if you haven't
but this is one of those things were
kind of teased is that the idea that
Billy has lost someone and that's really
kind of seems to be as motivation behind
doing all this and so what it does is it
switches over to Mother's Milk right
does this next so really the last member
that he recruits for the team and
Mother's Milk for all is his size and
his bravado and how big he seems to be
really seems to be a softy in a lot of
different ways because when he's talking
to Billy he's kind of like look my
involvement and all that wet work stuff
that black ops CIA you know all that
kind of spy business that's all done I
don't want to have anything to do with
that
done with all that stuff but the funny
thing is that when his daughter walks in
who's dressed like a woman of the night
when Janine comes walking in she just
kind of starts mouthing off and is just
got like I can go where I want and talk
to who I want I can dress how I want
there's nothing you can do about all
that kind of stuff it's kind of
interesting because what Mother's Milk
seems to have been doing is trying to
settle down and basically like going
through kind of like adopting kids
things like that trying to bring them up
and give them a more productive life so
they could have an actual future as
opposed to coming to like gang violence
or drugs or any number of negative
negative influences and so what happens
is billy butcher steps in and so when
billy butcher when he goes outside and
starts talking to these guys he's really
like seedy looking guys bendji Dean's
hanging out with it's kind of like hey
look he to go back in there and
basically apologize to your dad and one
of the guys pulls a gun
of course billy butcher takes the gun
smashes it the guys drive off because
you know they're cowards and then in
turn billy butcher starts talking in
Jenin and this is a very important thing
because up to this point billy butchers
kind of been presented to us as a guy
who just doesn't like he's like it's my
way or the highway either you're in the
way or you're helping me along the way
but having this conversation with
jeaneen chosen to be a lot deeper than
that
insofar as he's talking to her and
basically saying hey look like your
father puts put clothes on your back
like you're able to live the life that
you live because your father's working
as a soft to make it that way so if you
want to be an adult and if you really
want it you really want to have your
freedom as an adult and make your own
choices in this world didn't leave you
can go back to your mom's house but
she's a drug addict and alcoholics who
knows what fatal befall you if you want
to have a productive life if you want to
have a life that goes somewhere then you
got to respect the rules of the house
right you can't have it both ways you
can't say on one hand I will take
everything that you give me to support
me and make sure I'm okay and then the
other hand say but I don't have to do
what you want me to do I can just go out
and do my own thing right you don't get
to have it both ways like if you if you
want to if you want the benefit of
living under another person's house you
got to follow the rules of living out of
that person's house and so it's a cool
little moment when he talks to her
because she basically says get back in
there and apologize and start dressing
you like you have some self-respect it's
a cool little moment it's a cool little
thing there but ultimately you end up
having Billy butcher who goes back to
Huey and says hey look I know you're on
the fence about this that's fine take
some time to think about it because a
lot of this takes place in Wisconsin so
he's like I know you're on the fence
about it that's fine here's here's a
whole bunch of cash saving a book of
flight to to America and basically you
know meet me in New York and and we'll
go from there if I don't see you there
then you don't wanna be a part of the
team if I do see you there
we'll go forward accordingly so it was
cool it's forming the team of the boys
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here too comments explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later purse
[Music]